مساء الخير فرص المشير خليفه حفتر فى دخول
طرابلس والسيطره عليها و كذلك السيطره على
كامل الغرب الليبي محدوده وامامها عقبات
كثيره جدا لكن فرص ليبيا في ان تعود دوله
كما كانت اذا فشلت في م ساعات سوف تكون
شبه معدومه لسنوات طويله قادمه
ليه
لان احنا نفهم معنى كلمه الدوله ولا
الدوله في ابسط تعريف لها هي سلطه تحتكر
لنفسها استخدام السلاح على بقعه جغرافيه
محدده من الخارج استخدام السلاح وانفاذ
القانون اذا هذه السلطه افردت في استخدام
القوه ضد مواطنيها تكون تظل دوله ولكنها
دوله مستبده اما اذا فشلت في احتقار
استخدام القوه والسلاح وتعددت الجهاد داخل
ا الجهات التي تستخدم السلاح تصبح هذه
الدوله دوله فاشله مش فاشله بمعنى الناحيه
ولكنها يعني عجزه عن اداء مهامها وفي حاله
ليبيا المثاليه تحققوا او ان موجودين
تحققوا ليبيا انتقلت من نموذج الدوله
المستبده تحت حكم
الزعيم معمر القذافي الى نموذج الدوله
الفاشله اللي فيها حكومه في الشرق وحكومه
في الغرب وجنوب من فلك تماما وعشرات
الميليشيات المسلحه اللي موجوده في مختلف
المدن الليبيه
وسته نصف مليون مواطن السلاح اللي متوفر و
فقالت قدرت الامم المتحده من 15 الى 18
مليون قطعه سلاح يعني اكثر من قطعه قطعه
سلاح الى كل مواطن الوضع المثالي انه
الدوله الليبيه تقوم ب توافق الاطراف
المختلفه و رضاها عن انهم يعيشوا تحت سقف
واحد وبالتالي بدؤوا بالتراضي عمليه بناء
الدوله ومؤسساتها المختلفه لكن هذا لم
يحدث من 2011 والى الان ولا يبدو في الافق
وارد انه يحصل في المدى المنظور ولا حتى
المدى البعيد انا اللي بقول الكلام ده
لانه شهاده المبعوث الاممي اه غسان سلامه
وتؤكد هذا الكلام غسان سلامه الكلام خطير
جدا بيقول انه مثل عظيم جدا انه كل
الاطراف الليبيه متوافقه مصالحها متوافقه
على استمرار الصراع وليس حسنه وان الصراع
ده بيوتيك صبيحه كل يوم مليونير مليونير
جديد طبعا المليونير ده مش من اهل البلد
يعني مش من افراد الشعب العاديين ولكن
ولكن من النخب اللي هي بتمثل قاده
المليشيات والعاملين فيها وقال في الاحزاب
السياسيه
والناس اللي هم يعني متحكمين في صناعه
القرار الليبي في هذا الجو الفوضوي
وبالتالي ما فيش رغبه لدى هذه الاطراف في
انهى
تتصالح مع بعض الاطراف لم ت ت صالح يكون
الحل الثاني الحل الثاني لقيام الدوله هو
استخدام القوه ال الدول بتنشا احيانا
باستخدام القوه والقوه بتكون ضروره عند
الانشاء او لاستمرار الدوله
الامثله على ذلك يعني كثيره جدا الدوله
السعوديه مثلا كيف نشات الدوله الدوله
السعوديه ان يشهد باستخدام القوه لتوحيد
كل هذه القبائل تحت رايه واحده
الولايات المتحده نفسها نشات بالتوافق
لكنها احتاج الى القوه حتى تستمر بعد
الحرب الاهليه في الولايات المتحده الوضع
ال عندنا في الوقت الحالي احنا قدام
معسكرين معسكر يقودوا الجنرال خليفه حفتر
والمعسكر ده رفع شعار اعاده بناء الدوله
الوطنيه مره اخرى وهو يرى انه اعاده
بنائها لن يتم الا بشرط اساسي الشرط
الاساسي هو اخضاع كل الميليشيات اللي
موجوده على كامل الارض الليبيه تحت لواء
جيش واحد اما ان هي تسلم سلاحه او تنضم
بسلاحه الى هذا الجيش وتخضع الى سلطه
الدوله ومعسكر اخر اللي هو موجود في الغرب
تحت لواء
حكومه الوفاق لكن حكومه الوفاق من هي
المعترف بها معترف بها دوليا
لكن شرعيتها تظل مثل شرعيه الرئيس هادي في
اليمن شرعيه صوريه والمتحكم الاساسي هي
الجماعات الكثيره التي تحمل السلاح هذه
الجماعات او هذه الميليشيات مقسمه على
اساس قبلي جغرافي وسياسي
وانتماءات اخرى جزء منها بينتمي الى
المشروع الاسلام السياسي او جماعات
الاسلام السياسي وليس كلها هذه الجماعات
عندها مشاكل كثيره جدا حتى لو افترضنا
انهم كلهم فاضل وجادين ما عندهمش مشاكل
ولا المصالح ولم يستفيدوا من الفوضى اللي
موجودين وان محافظتهم على خليفه حفتر اه
بعضها سليم او حتى كلها سليمه مشكلتهم
الاساسيه هي فوجود هم انفسهم
بمعنى النقود جماعات مختلفه تحمل السلاح
وهذه الجماعات غير قادره مش على التوافق
مع فتره او غيره ولكن حتى مع نفسها وانه
الحكومه الموجوده هناك قياده السيارات مش
فشلت انهى تبسط سيطرتها على كامل الارض
اللي بيئه شرقا وغربا ولا في تخضع خليفه
حفتر او تتفهم مع هذه الجماعات فشلت حتى
فان هي تتوافق بينها وبين بعضها البعض
وعددت هذه الحكومه من 2015 يعني منذ اتفاق
الص خيارات والى الان
هي تصبح اه اه يعني الدوله على مساحه
طرابلس والغرب الليبي بجيش واحد فقط اللي
بيتحكم في مسار الاحداث هناك اللي هي
المصالح المتباينه والمتعارضه لهذه
المليشيات في المقابله احنا عندنا شخص
واحد اللي هو خليفه حفتر باجنده واضحه رغم
كل الصعوبات اللي موجوده في تركيبه وفي
جيش ولان هو الاقرب الى نموذج الجيش
الوطني
فهذا نموذج وهذا نموذج ال ال ال الحادث
الان انه خليفه حفتر بعدما سيطر على الشرق
من 2014 ثم ذهب الى الجنوب صحيح انه ما
صار شيء كامل لسيطره ان ما نجح الى حد
كبير والان يريد اتمام مهمته باتجاه غربا
لاتمام المشروع مسيطره على تراب الاصول
الثالث سيطلع على غرب ليبيا ويبقى كده تم
مشروع اه اللي هو فكره اه ان يكون كل
الجماعات المسلحه تحت لواء جهه واحده وهي
الجيش اللي هو قدام مهمته وعقبات كثيره
جدا العقبه الاولى ان الجماعات الكثيره
اللي موجوده في الغرب الليبي مستفيده من
الوضع القائم وبالتالي سوف تقاومه الى
اخره هذا واحد اثنين
الصوره الذهنيه لدى عدد كبير من النخب
الليبيه يعني المثقفين الليبيين اه يعني
في بعض الدول او الصوره الخارجيه عند بعض
الدول في صوره سلبيه ويشوفوا انه هو اعاده
انتاج مره اخرى الى معمر القذافي وبنسمع
على السنه بعض المثقفين الليبيين انه هما
مش عايزين خليفه حفتر لانه يعني ملوا من
لا يريدون ان يعيشوا مره اخرى تحت تجربه
الجنرال عسكري دكتاتوريه عسكريه
وكلامهم يحمل بعض الوكاله بس احنا بنتكلم
على احنا بن فاضل الاختيارات قال ايضا لو
ان هناك اختيار
خليفه حفتر وقدمنا نموذج الدوله الوطنيه
المدنيه اللي فيها
بعدنا ب دوله قانون يعني فصل بين السلطات
الى اخره قطعا لازم
الاخر
لكن اللي احنا قدمنا اختيار خليفه حفتر
وقدمنا نموذج المليشيات المتعدده المسلحه
حتى وان حسن نواياها وجودها في حد ذاته
عقبه امام قيام الدوله الليبيه الامر
الثالث وهو العقبه ايضا المهمه جدا هي
فكره تعارض الاجندات الدوليه
خليفه حفتر ومن معارضه الداعم الاساسي
خليفه حفتر هي ال مصر والامارات ومؤخرا
السعوديه وهذه الدول بدعم خليفه حفتر
لاعتبارات مختلفه اهمها انها شافه هو
الرهان ممكن لتحقيق او بسط النفوذ على
الليبيه وبالتالي ما تصبح
ليبيا مصدرا لتصدير كل العمليات الارهابيه
والجريمه المنظمه هو الارض منفرده نومانز
لاند او ارضا بلا صاحب
والامارات وهي طبعا بعيده يعني عن
الجغرافيه لكن هي عندها بتعتبر جزء من
مشروعها واستقرارها القضاء او محصله اي اه
مشروع سياسي يقوم على اساس الاسلام
السياسي سواء جماعه الاخوان المسلمين او
غيرها وتكلمنا فيها الكثير في جامعه اخرى
في دول اخرى بتدعم خليفه حفتر لاسباب
مختلفه
على راسها فرنسا مثلا اللي هي شايفه انه
لا حديث ابدا عن اي حلول في
الا بعد استقرار الاوضاع واستقرار الاوضاع
لن يتحقق الا عن طريق شخص واحد او جنرال
او الجيش او منظمه واحده عندها استعداد
انها تسيطر على انتشار السلاح والارهاب
والعمليات ال الاجرام المنظم او الكريم
المنظمه ودور تكلمنا عن هذا الكلام انضمت
اليه مؤخرا اه روسيا اليها مصالح كبيره اه
فيه الليبيه لكن
تعنين الاساسيين للمشير للمشير خليفه حفظه
ال ال المعارضين
بالدرجه الاولى وبالتالي محسوبين على حزب
طرابلس او جماعه طرابلس هم في الحقيقه
دولتين اساسيتين اقليميتين راح نتكلم على
تركيا و قطر ودول ايضا في صراع مستمره مع
المعسكر الاولاني على جبهات مختلفه
ثاني الدولتان هما من تدعمان جماعات
الاسلام السياسي اينما كان
وايضا نص والامارات والسعوديه
يحاصرون جماعات الاسلام السياسي اي النبا
كان على صعيد الدول الاقل الدوليه وعلى
صعيد الدول الاخرى في طول لم تكن متحمسه
الخليفه في بريطانيا وفي ايطاليا او سعي
الولايات المتحده لكن الدولي العامل
الاساسي فيها هو العامل الاساسي اللي
حضرها لمشروع خليفه حفتر هو مصالحها واذا
هي اه اه رات ان مصالحها يمكن ان تحقق
الخليفه حتى سوف تدعمه هي مقتنعه ان
الحكومه في طرابلس مشكلتها ان الحكومه في
طرابلس ضعيفه وانه كل هذا القدر من
الميليشيات يمثل خطر حتى على مصالحها
لكنها ليست واثقه ان ما يقوم به خليفه
حفتر سوف يحقق هذه المصالح مؤخرا بدا في
تغيير في هذا الموقف لانه لما خليفه حفتر
قرر ان في 4 ابريل الجاري قرر ان اه يتجه
الى الغرب بشان العمليه العسكريه على
طرابلس وجدنا انه الاعتراضات من هذه الدول
كانت اعتراضات فاتره و شكليه واقفلت
واكتفى وقت صرف على ادانات محدوده بمطالبه
جميع الاطراف بضبط النفس
بالتمني بعدم اراقه الدماء حتى الولايات
المتحده
اللي اضطرت لاخلاء حوالي جندي لم يكن احد
يعلم بوجود هم في الغرب الليبي قصه ثانيه
طالبت المشير خليفه حفتر بالتوقف على
القتال ثم يعني لم لم تحرك ساكنا معنى كده
لو كانت جاده في ذلك لها البلد باستخدام
العقوبات ضد
استخدام القوه العسكريه ضد ولكن الحقيقه
هي الم تفعل اي شيء في انتظار ان الراي
اللي ممكن يحقق ما يمكن ان يريح الجميع
بتحقيق مسلح كاسح على الجماعات اللي
موجوده في الغرب وده هو الامر اللي ممكن
الحقيقه يبدو انه يواجه فيه صعوبات لفتره
طويله لكن مره اخرى الجماعه ال او
الدولتين الاساسيتين اللتين الاعمال الغرب
او يعاديان في القطر والتركيه دول الاسباب
اللي تكلمنا عنهم قبل كده مرات العديده
اذا نجح المشير اه خليفه حفتر في مساله
منكون نحنا قدام نموذج الدوله الليبيه قبل
ما كانت 2011 اللي هي الدوله اللي فيها
حاكم عنده قدره على بسط سيطرته على كل
الاطراف اللي بياكل ربما يكون شيعي يرقى
الى احلام الليبيين ولكنه يسمح الى ليبيا
ان تكون دوله طبيعيه ونس تامن فيها على
ارزق هاو ممكن تبدا تمارس نشاطها وممكن
يبقى فيه امل انه تقوم دوله في المستقبل
الرجل عنده خمسه وسبعين سنه ممكن الوضع
يتطور سياسيا الى وضع افضل لاحقا ممكن
ممكن ممكن لا لكن اذا فشل خليفه هو او
غيره في تحقيق هذا المسعى الضروري
لقيام الدوله الليبيه تتكلم انه ليبيا سوف
تصبح بؤره لكل الجماعات المسلحه وكل
الجماعات الارهابيه وكل عصابات الاجرام
المنظم تصبح اقرب الي نموذج الصومال الذي
يعيش في ظلام وفوضى منذ عشرات السنوات
اشكركم والى لقاء اخر ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]